[Music]
in toilet torture news submitted by Seth
from Washington Oh simple I like that a
kid was taken to the hospital with
constipation because of her school's
strict bathroom policy oh dude I'm gonna
tell you guys now and tell your kids if
your school ever tells your kids note
you can't go to bathroom just [ __ ] your
pants in the room they'll learn do you
want to teach your a lesson or you want
to be known as a [ __ ] boy you're right
[ __ ] you're thinking like an adult right
now I'm not like a kid who has to do
with consequence you gotta protect their
reputations like that I had a [ __ ] kid
in my class too
yeah in the middle of the show and tell
I smelled something next me that was all
let me shot his pants and then years
later in middle school you try to make
fun of me and I was like Patrick do you
want me to tell people what happened in
fifth grade no please don't
music no I'm the [ __ ] kid oh no oh I was
the fart boy I don't I don't think I
could digest Doritos properly I always
loved them huh yeah like I would always
try to eat them during like recess I
loved them but then I know as soon as I
come back from recess I would start
getting bloated and then like I'm always
trying to like let them out little by
little but then they would start
squeaking or doing weird [ __ ] like [ __ ]
how do you control like how much comes
out of here I'm tryna he's doing a kid
like when you fart you feel so ashamed
in the whole class looks at you and
she's like a balloon these things out
without if it's not like they were
smelly it's just the noise I just didn't
get it out so that my stomach doesn't
hurt did you know that women I have well
I guess men if you're into it too we
have a we have a silencer for our farts
what is realizes did you know what do
you sneeze while you fell silent your
farts I didn't know that yeah dude like
cuz it has to go through like a like a
layer it's silence your fart so whenever
I like it's my first night like spending
it over no not you guys still up for
national silence mine
that's what I do would like it's my
first night or whatever we're like when
you're early in the relationship and you
guys are spend the night together I
always wear a thong because it silences
my farts this is like yeah this is a tip
that I should throw out it does it's a
burglar they like it doesn't slide and I
can see the farts there's like something
in between the kind of separates it just
a little bit usually way it's for the
air to come out my dumb ass is holding
it the whole time what did you do to me
to diffuse the sound I just try to let
the air out not at a certain velocity
that doesn't create guys see now there's
a solution for guys give yourself a
wedgie with your boxers and you can fart
silence so that a girl takes off your
[ __ ] pants and they see you have a
wedgie with the boxers that's I think we
know because the girls take his pants
down from the back to Heisey just looks
like she's seen some [ __ ] Joey just went
down on each other Joey let me put my
pants on backwards to get some DMS from
you guys saying oh my god Gina thank you
you saved my life already saved my life
from crying when I have to clench my
butthole because of you even if you
don't have a thong and a regular and
we're just [ __ ] give yourself a
wedgie really quick or I do the butt
spread to Jess so like if i'm like if
i'm like say phoenix suka and i know i
have to fart really bad i just like
spread my butt a little bit doesn't work
for me goes like this
they say the last words they're gonna
get really compete so this little girl
at her school children aged 4 to 11 must
take what they think they're gonna need
in the like to the toilet stall the
tissue paper is gonna talk about here
because they don't actually have toilet
rolls in the stalls and so because of
that there was this little girl this
four-year-old little girl who was so so
I want at one point she didn't grab
enough tissue for herself so I ended up
having to like soil herself a little bit
when she pants back up to go and get
more paper ties by that so she would not
use a restroom when she was at the at
school got shy but that's not her though
you have to learn the waddle and
sometimes out man you never know kids
can control their [ __ ] alright the
waddle what's the waddle you don't have
enough toilet paper or you're out of
toilet paper yeah you don't pull your
pants all the way up yeah not even close
yeah you cover what are your ass cheeks
close so they don't open if [ __ ]
vacuum about dirty they're gonna where
she's four yeah she's still learning the
ways of the pit still on her she's
already broken for like a year for like
- she actually but yeah so [ __ ] tiger
this will go to the toilet we bought up
and laughs at it like it's a chore like
a toy or joke I mean no need to learn
how to use this thing toilet why should
sit on the floor runs away know each
other cuz I think
you literally would you take off his
diaper and then just [ __ ] right in front
of the door so then when you enter it
[ __ ] smear oh my god he did that one
Wow the magic of motherhood Jesus Christ
yeah yeah wonderful stories wonderful
other times you'd [ __ ] right in front of
the toilet I'm like yeah anyway so this
little girl had to be hospitalized oh I
know this does happen in Wales and so
now the school has changed their policy
and will install totally P why didn't
they promote that they said because they
wanted to prevent the kids from clogging
the toilets oh that makes all the other
[ __ ] schools though like we're all
right we always have like water or I
mean paper wads yeah there's so many
[ __ ] kids in school and everything else
those boys a couple toys that are
definitely our order my element always
along stop just people pissing purposely
like on the outside like right guys
reasonable you use the girls bathroom at
Isaac school cuz I went to go pick them
up and had to pee really bad so I went
in and on the toilet paper roll thingy
they wrote bullcrap but then right next
to it they said this is [ __ ] where I'm
like how cute like they didn't want to
cuss but then they ended up cussing
remember the first or second grade
there'd be kids that spent entire recess
in the bathroom just [ __ ] wreaking
havoc like you know that you remember
the [ __ ] soap dispenser with the pink
powder and you got to hit that thing
you're just [ __ ] like this like the
whole [ __ ] recess yeah and it's all
on the ground they're [ __ ] gone like
this just pulling like the hordes heart
just watching [ __ ] it waster a whole
recess on this and I've wasted watching
tonight yeah you're obviously the
lookout I love judging but he's still
their life but that's kid so I
understand I don't have stuff like that
cuz kids are [ __ ]
I like peeing on people's shoes
when I just wait and then when someone
stands next to me I start beating on
their shoe are you this last week last
week at the airport like it with your
shoelaces it gets soaked in that
[ __ ] kids remember in kept low
when it rains the [ __ ] rivers on the
side of the road and doesn't drink we
went to the same high school together
oh yeah in front of the school right
yeah because it's so much like it goes
over the curbs and onto the sidewalk it
was pretty bad drainage system in our in
our area dude California or LA I
remember having if I can dry my socks
and the hand dryer things all right so
now the mom is saying that tell me yeah
at this right you got all the hot she
you're really good at finding that out
you've had emotional distress are you
saying that the little girl now she's
even having trouble going she made fun
of her something a missus oh oh it's
because when she ended up soiling
herself she had to tell the teacher but
she had to tell her in front of the
whole class and everyone pointed laughs
I don't know but it sounds like they did
it's like a [ __ ] 90s movie you know
great comedian later on my stand-up
comedian this is good good stuff this
build is good it builds good character
mm-hmm is it true that if you get really
scared you can actually [ __ ] yourself oh
because they could like take a bill
haunted house or something like that
oh yeah if you were holding it in and
yeah maybe but then like if it doesn't
just come out of nowhere they won't ever
peed when they laugh I am yeah because
I've heard that had to pee and I even
just squirt it out yeah I think they're
a fountain sometimes I start when I pee
you fart when you pee like your video
have you ever farted and burped at the
same time yeah yeah that's
they say that when you when you do that
your brain just took a screenshot you
ever try to mask your fart with the
sneeze and you're like oh he was just
easing the both times this guy's sneeze
is smelly driving a car with Joe he
farts then he hawks his hoard he's like
yeah this guy this guy in front of me
you know the billion other person in the
elevator with you in the car all true
that's right
[Music]
[Music]